In a history of science museum in Florence, Italy
is the middle finger of our modern age
I’ve been lucky enough to actually go to this museum
and it is incredible
in there among the armillary spheres
and the lodestones and the antique telescopes
there is a literal piece of humanity
a middle finger
and it is kept in a little shrine like a saintly relic
but this is not a piece of a saint
it is a piece of an enemy of the church
it is part of a heretic. This...
Is Galileo’s middle finger
It took a while for Galileo’s skeleton to age into something worth collecting
sort of like a, like a fine wine
so it wasn’t until 1737 or 95 years after he died
that one Anton Francesco Gori went and decided that
he need to collect a few pieces of Galileo Galilei
Now this wasn’t without a president
there was a long tradition of preserving venerated individuals in Catholicism
Except this was a little different
Anton Francesco Gori was not a religious fanatic
He was a Galileo groupie
What he did is he snapped of three fingers
and a few other bits which we get into later
he took his thumb, his index finger, and his middle finger
is this your index finger?
He was taking scientific relics
These were the fingers that Galileo used when he adjusted his telescope
He was in essence creating the first scientific saint
Oftentimes Galileo is portrayed as being versus the church
It was Galileo and the church in this pit match against each other
It was a little more complicated than that
his theory that the earth did in fact revolve around the sun
and not the other way around
and the church actually said “OK, that’s fine”
“but you just, you gotta represent both sides of the argument"
so Galileo did this
but the guy who represented the church in it’s geocentric position
did such a terrible job
that when the book was published
people basically thought the Galileo had punked the pope
After this the Pope who was already paranoid
and worried about looking weak
came down and sentenced Galileo to house arrest
basically for the remainder of his life
But it doesn’t mean that Galileo ever truly abandoned his faith
ultimately whether Galileo’s middle finger is
pointed up at the heavens
where he saw the beauty of god in math and physics
or out to the church
who condemned him for his scientific views
is really for the viewer to decide.
His thumb and other finger were also taken
and they actually weren’t discovered until 2009
when they were seen on an auction block
and someone put it together and was like
“I feel like these are the other two fingers that have been missing"
so they have been reunited
as has a tooth
and if you are on a Galileo corpse tour of Italy
you should go to the university of Padua
because they’ve got his vertebrae